corver gives it up to middleton launches
a three
and he's fouled that has been the story
of the game it's happened seven or eight
times
where a three-point shooter has been
fouled and middleton with a chance to
tie the game
at the foul line
[Applause]
if you're goran dragach i i disagree
with the call
and you don't have the challenge
upper body moved enough all right 4.3
miami inbounds
here's butler with three butler with two
with one
butler against matthews gets it away and
no good
do we have a foul we do a foul is called
and jimmy butler can win it at the line
another jump shooter fouled
let's see if it's matthews or giannis
who they get
and they're gonna look two to make sure
that butler got it off in time and also
with the clock going to zeroes okay how
much time is on the clock when the foul
occurred here
is it giannis
where's the foul there
the bucks used their challenge already
they get giannis for the foul let's see
the left hand here does he
put some contact there puts it on the
body of the shooter jimmy butler
let's see if he gets it always just make
sure that he gets it away at a time it
appeared that he did
and yep it's definitely out of his hand
and there's the contact
not much but like the dragon butler
probably
here we go
[Applause]
got it
so this is just for the scoring here but
miami up two nothing in the series
[Applause]
wow after blowing the lead
[Applause]
[Music]
and milwaukee tying the game with three
free throws by chris middleton jimmy
butler is